en este vídeo vamos a encontrar el
estado de oxidación de varias moléculas
en algún vídeo anterior ya vimos cuál es
la definición del estado de oxidación y
también vimos cómo calcularlo así es que
pues vamos a empezar con el metano lo
que queremos hacer es encontrar cuál es
el estado de oxidación de este carbono
una forma de hacer eso que es una forma
un poco más de química general es tomar
este metano y decir el hidrógeno
generalmente tiene un estado de
oxidación de más 1 y aquí tenemos 4
hidrógenos entonces en total tenemos un
más 4 y luego la suma de los estados de
oxidación tiene que ser igual a 0
entonces sabemos que el estado de
oxidación del carbono tiene que ser
igual a menos 4 aunque entonces este
carbono tiene un estado de oxidación de
menos 4 porque aquí tenemos un solo
carbono pero bueno lo que vamos a hacer
ahora es verificar esto con nuestra
estructura de puntos
bueno hay que recordar que cuando
estamos usando las estructuras de puntos
para encontrar el estado de oxidación en
lo que tenemos que pensar es en los
electrones que forman los enlaces y cada
enlace está formado por dos electrones y
tenemos que poner todos los electrones
que forman todos los enlaces
y ahora sí ya podemos pensar en el
estado de oxidación del carbono
empezamos con el número de electrones de
valencia que se supone que debe de tener
el átomo y sabemos que el carbono se
supone que tiene 4 electrones de
valencia y a ese número le restamos el
número de electrones de valencia que
tiene el átomo una vez que ya está
enlazado aunque el número de electrones
de valencia que realmente tiene este
carbono en esta estructura de puntos
pero ahora tenemos que tomar mucho en
cuenta en que estos enlaces covalentes
son iónicos y entonces el átomo más
electrón negativo se va a quedar con
todos los electrones del enlace y
entonces tenemos que pensar muy bien en
qué tan el electrón negativo es cada
átomo y en este momento en particular
estamos comparando que tan el electrón
negativo es el carbono comparado con qué
tan el electrón negativo es el hidrógeno
entonces cuál es más electrón negativo
bueno sabemos que el carbono es más
electro negativo que el hidrógeno y
entonces se va a quedar con ambos
electrones de este enlace que se va a
quedar con estos electrones los abraza
súper fuerte y lo mismo sucede en este
otro enlace como el carbono es más
electro negativo que el hidrógeno
entonces se va a quedar con estos dos
electrones y lo mismo sucede con estos
otros enlaces de aquí así es que como
podemos observar el carbono está rodeado
por 8 electrones de valencia aquí vamos
a contar los 1 2 3 4 5 6
78 así es que a este 4 le tenemos que
restar 8 y nos queda 4 menos ocho es
menos 4 por lo que el estado de
oxidación de este carbono en el metano
es menos 4 como ya lo habíamos visto por
acá pero bueno vamos con la siguiente
molécula y teno o etileno c 2 h 4 y cuál
es el estado de oxidación de cualquiera
de estos carbonos pues veamos lo paso
por paso
generalmente el hidrógeno tiene un
estado de oxidación de más 1 pero
tenemos cuatro de esos hidrógenos
entonces en total tenemos más 4 y la
suma de los estados de oxidación tiene
que ser igual a cero así es que los
carbonos tienen que aportar un estado de
oxidación de menos 4 pero pues tenemos 2
carbonos entonces cada uno de ellos debe
de tener un estado de oxidación de menos
porque tenemos 2 carbonos ok
bueno vamos a verificarlo para que
coloquemos por aquí los electrones que
forman los enlaces
y calculemos el estado de oxidación de
los carbonos usando nuestra fórmula que
ya pusimos nuestros electrones de
valencia por acá y lo que vamos a hacer
es enfocarnos en uno de los dos carbonos
aunque por ejemplo vamos a tomar el
carbono de la derecha tenemos que pensar
en la electro negatividad de estos
átomos y el carbono es más electro
negativo que el hidrógeno por lo cual se
va a quedar con estos dos electrones de
este enlace y por acá en este enlace
sucede lo mismo el carbono es más
electro negativo que el hidrógeno y por
lo tanto se queda con todos los
electrones de este enlace y por acá
tenemos algo muy interesante porque
ahora tenemos un doble enlace entre dos
carbonos y pues los dos son igual de
electro negativos entonces qué vamos a
hacer con estos cuatro electrones pues
como los carbonos son igual de electro
negativos entonces lo que hacemos es
dividirlos a la mitad y entonces un
carbono se queda con dos electrones
el otro carbono se queda con los otros
dos y ahora sí ya podemos calcular el
estado de oxidación de este carbono
usando esta fórmula porque generalmente
el carbono tiene 4 electrones de
valencia ya eso le tenemos que restar el
número de electrones alrededor del
carbono en nuestro dibujo entonces vamos
a contarlos y aquí estamos tomando en
cuenta muchísimo la electro negatividad
entonces alrededor del carbono tenemos
456 electrones 6 electrones así es que
el estado de oxidación de este carbono
es 4 - 6 o sea menos 2 que es justo lo
que habíamos calculado por acá ahora
recuerda también que esto sucede para
los dos carbonos entonces si nos fijamos
en este carbono y asignamos rápidamente
todos los electrones que le tocan a este
carbono podemos ver también aquí en este
dibujo que este carbono tiene un estado
de oxidación de menos 2 como ya lo
sabíamos pero bueno vamos con otro
ejemplo tenemos aquí se h 2 o
formaldehído y sabemos que el oxígeno
generalmente tiene un estado de
oxidación de menos 2 tenemos un solo
oxígeno por lo cual eso nos aporta un
total de menos 2 el hidrógeno
generalmente tiene un estado de
oxidación de más 1 pero tenemos dos
hidrógenos entonces tenemos un total de
más
la suma de todo esto tiene que ser igual
a cero así es que el carbono debe de
aportar cero
o sea que esté carbono debe de tener un
estado de oxidación cero entonces vamos
con nuestra estructura de puntos
colocamos todos los electrones que
forman los enlaces para que sea más
fácil encontrar los estados de oxidación
y nos ponemos a pensar en las
diferencias electro negativas
sabemos que el carbono es más electro
negativo que el hidrógeno por lo cual se
queda con estos electrones y también con
estos electrones pero ahora tenemos que
comparar qué tan el electrón negativo es
el carbono con respecto al oxígeno y
pues el oxígeno es más el electrón
negativo que el carbono entonces el
oxígeno se va a quedar con todos los
electrones de este doble enlace ok
este carbono no se queda con ni uno de
estos cuatro electrones
y estamos pensando en estados de
oxidación
entonces el carbono se queda con 4
electrones a su alrededor
4 el carbón no se supone que tiene 4
electrones de valencia y en este dibujo
está rodeado por 4 electrones entonces
el estado de oxidación es 4 menos 40
aunque justo lo que habíamos dicho en
las moléculas de formaldehído los
carbonos tienen un estado de oxidación
de 0 y ahora lo que podemos hacer es
pensar en el estado de oxidación del
oxígeno por ejemplo aunque hay aquí
estamos diciendo que es menos 2
así es que regresamos a la estructura de
puntos para que el oxígeno está aquí y
se está quedando con todos estos
electrones y para sacar su estado de
oxidación lo que hacemos primero es
pensar cuántos electrones de valencia
tiene el oxígeno y pues por donde se
encuentra en la tabla periódica el
oxígeno debería de tener 6 electrones de
valencia y cuántos electrones tiene a su
alrededor en este dibujo y tomando en
cuenta la electro negatividad
pues aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8
electrones a su alrededor y 6 menos ocho
nos da un estado de oxidación de menos 2
y ahora vamos con el hidrógeno
el hidrógeno debería de tener un
electrón de valencia pero como es menos
el electrón negativo que el carbono
entonces no se queda con ni un solo
electrón y a su alrededor no tiene
ningún electrón así es que 10 nos da un
estado de oxidación de más 1 que es lo
que teníamos aquí y lo mismo sucede para
este otro hidrógeno nunca así es que
como podemos observar esta fórmula
también funciona para otros átomos vamos
con otro ejemplo y aquí lo que tenemos
es ácido fórmico se h2o2 el oxígeno
debería de tener un estado de oxidación
de menos
tenemos 2 oxígenos y eso nos da un total
de menos 4 el hidrógeno generalmente
tiene un estado de oxidación de más 1
tenemos dos hidrógenos y eso nos da un
total de más 2 y la suma de todo esto
nos debe de dar 0 por lo cual el carbono
debe de aportar un +2 y es un solo
carbono entonces seguramente el estado
de oxidación de este carbono es más 2
así es que pues vamos a la estructura de
puntos
empezamos colocando todos los electrones
que forman estos enlaces
y queremos encontrar el estado de
oxidación de este carbono tenemos que
pensar en la electro negatividad de
estos átomos el carbono es más electro
negativo que el hidrógeno por lo cual se
queda con estos dos electrones pero por
acá el oxígeno es más electro negativo
que el carbono por lo cual se va a
quedar con esos dos electrones y lo
mismo sucede por acá aunque ahí el
oxígeno es más electro negativo por lo
cual se queda con todos los electrones
entonces cuál es el estado de oxidación
del carbono en el ácido fórmico pues el
carbono debería de tener 4 electrones de
valencia y a eso le restamos el número
de electrones que se quedan alrededor
del carbono una vez que tomamos en
cuenta la electro negatividad y aquí
pues tenemos 2 electrones alrededor del
carbono entonces 4 menos 2 nos da un
estado de oxidación de más 2
a este carbono justo como habíamos dicho
por acá y está muy interesante no en
cada una de las moléculas que hemos
visto el carbono ha tenido un estado de
oxidación distinto y eso es algo que
hace que el carbono sea súper especial
pero bueno ahora vamos a ver qué pasa
con el dióxido de carbono el oxígeno
generalmente tiene un estado de
oxidación de menos 2 pero tenemos 2
oxígenos entonces tenemos un total de
menos 4 y la suma debería de ser igual a
0 por lo cual aquí tenemos un +4 así es
que este carbón no debería de tener un
estado de oxidación de más 4 vamos a la
estructura de puntos vamos a dibujar los
electrones que forman los enlaces aquí
están todos estos y bueno los oxígenos
son más electro negativos que el carbono
por lo cual se van a quedar con todos
los electrones aunque hay déjame lo
dibujo por acá de una forma más clara
o sea este oxígeno con sus 4 electrones
por aquí y estos electrones que forman
los enlaces están por acá este oxígeno
es más electro negativo que el carbono
por lo cual se va a quedar con todos
ellos y por aquí tenemos al otro oxígeno
con sus pares de electrones libres y
estos 4 electrones que forman el enlace
doble como el oxígeno es más electro
negativo se va a quedar con todos ellos
y el carbono se va a quedar por acá sin
un solo electrón entonces para encontrar
el estado de oxidación de este carbono
pensamos
ok el carbono debería de tener 4
electrones de valencia pero no tiene ni
un solo electrón a su alrededor
entonces 40 nos da un estado de
oxidación más 4 tal cual como habíamos
dicho por acá y el oxígeno pues el
oxígeno debería de tener 6 electrones de
valencia - a su alrededor tiene 12345678
electrones a su alrededor o sea menos 8
y 6 menos 8 nos da un estado de
oxidación de menos 2 y también tal cual
como lo dijimos pero bueno vamos al
principio vamos a ver todos los estados
de oxidación que hemos visto para el
carbono
arriba en el metano el carbono tenía un
estado de oxidación de menos 4 luego de
menos 2 más abajo encontramos un carbono
con estado de oxidación cero y otro con
estado de oxidación de más 2 y
finalmente llegamos a un carbono con
estado de oxidación de más 4 así es que
el carbono tiene un rango de estado de
oxidación desde menos 4 hasta más 4 y
bueno claro que el carbono también puede
tener un estado de oxidación de más 3 o
cualquier valor entero en medio
simplemente no hice tantos ejemplos